suite c'est l'invité de parer direct
elle s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est
vous patrick imbert bonjour et bienvenue
sur ce plateau merci d'être là vous êtes
réalisateur on vous doit le grand
méchant renard césar du meilleur film
d'animation c'était en 2018
avec benjamin lavagne est votre dernier
film sommet des dieux est en lice à
nouveau pour ce prix qui sera décerné le
25 février le sommet des dieux c'est
l'everest patrick imbert 8848 mètres le
toit du monde c'est là que vous vous
nous emmenez avec ce film qui vient de
sortir en dvd on regarde quelques images
sommet de l'everest a été atteint en
1953 mais ce n'était pas la première
tentative
ça fait soixante dix ans qu'on le
cherche manaurie si quelqu'un avait
retrouvé en forêt est pas la peine de
s'énerver explique utilité à bout jauge
se tue pas disparu depuis des années et
hop il refait surface avec l'appareil de
mallory et malori a atteint le sommet ça
peut changer l'histoire de l'alpinisme
s'il vous plaît laissez-moi grimper avec
vous je ferai tout ce que vous direz
mais tant qu'elle se porte mal cette
ascension surtout pour lui
ne cherche pas à le suivre à tout prix
corps n'est pas fait pour survivre à
cette inquiétude
on a perdu trop de temps
trop courte
réveille toi les soirs
[Musique]
fait ça
une fois qu'on ya goûté on peut plus
s'en passer
il ya plus que ça qui compte
[Musique]
voilà ce sommet des dieux est une
adaptation d'un manga du même nom signée
du japonais jirô tanigushi ces cinq
tomes 1500 pages qu'il a fallu condensé
en 90 minutes vous dites que c'est votre
everest personnel oui enfin déjà un film
c'est un everest parce que c'est
compliqué à faire un film d'animation
encore plus hélas oui parce qu'il ya un
matériau assez riche mais déjà il ya un
matériau donc on va pas se plaindre et
c'est que c'est évidemment on ne peut
pas mettre les 1500 pages donc lé choix
qui se font un il y en a certains qui se
font un peu tout seul et puis d'autres
il faut chercher vous avez mis comme un
temps alors en fabrication pure ces 2
1/2 mais après ça tient pas compte de
toute la période de d'écriture du
scénario de maturation va dire du projet
ça ça prend des années ce qui est assez
dingue dans votre histoire personnelle
avec ce film c'est que la montagne ce
n'est absolument pas votre adultes ou
non non non et non non mais c'est ça qui
est ça qui est marrant déjà parce que
moi en fait je donc je n'y connais rien
et j'ai lu la bd j'ai adoré donc pas
pour des raisons de montagne mais pour
des raisons de narrative en fait parce
que je trouve que c'est une bonne
histoire et c'est un peu ce que j'ai
essayé de faire avec le film j'ai voulu
un peu redonné aux spectateurs ce que
moi j'ai ressenti en lisant la halle
amédée et heureusement qu'on fait pas
que des choses sur des sujets qu'on
connaît sinon on ferait pas grand chose
en fait alors à propos de l'histoire
précisément suis à bout qui est un
grimpeur taciturne un taiseux habité par
l' envie d'aller toujours plus haut et
un journaliste japonais qui veut entre
autres choses raconté l'histoire de cet
alpiniste sur fond d'un mystère à ce
jour jamais vraiment résolu qui est
arrivé en premier en haut de l'everest
ouais alors ça c'est la partie vrai en
fait c'est la partie historique
ccc mallory et irvine qui en 1924 fond
la dernière partie de l'ascension pour
tenter d'atteindre le sommet et puissant
jamais redescendu on ne sait pas s'ils
ont un tel sommet ou pas mais on sait
qu'ils avaient un petit appareil photo
dans leur poche donc évidemment s'il
arrive au sommet mme allemand une
première photo pour avoir la preuve de
leur réussite et on se dit toujours que
si on avait six ont retrouvé les corps
et qu'on avait l'appareil photo on
saurait
mais sauf que depuis le livre le sam et
des dieux a été écrit avant qu'on
retrouve le corps de marie depuis il a
été retrouvé il n'avait pas l'appareil
photo sur lui donc le mystère est un
type voilà hélas la première ascension
homologué date de 1905 oui trois lacs
est central du film en réalité au delà
de l'histoire de mallory c'est celle de
l'absolu celle qui permet de répondre à
la question qu'est ce qui pousse ces
hommes et ces femmes à se lancer dans de
waimes et même plus généralement c'est
pourquoi on fait les choses en fait et
c'est essayer je pense que c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai pu faire ce film qui suit
pas du tout alpinisme c'est que parce
que moi j'ai envoyé un parallèle avec la
création artistique c'est à dire mais
pourquoi on fait ça pour quoi moi je
dessine en fait j'ai là j'ai pas de
réponse précise on le fait parce qu'en
fait on a envie de faire ça et toutes
proportions gardées en fait ces gens là
font à peu près ça sauf que c'est pour
eux c'est beaucoup plus dangereux
étonnement risque rien dessinant mais
c'est oui en fait on ne peut pas s'en
empêcher donc l'histoire de l'appareil
c'est comme prétexte à raconter
l'histoire de gens comme ça voilà sauf
qu effectivement l'everest en 70 ans
pour ne parler que de l'everest se sont
bien sûr plusieurs milliers d'ha sont
sept ascensions c'est un site 300 morts
qu'est-ce que vous avez compris de ce
rapport à la mort précisément mais ce
que j'ai compris en fait j'ai cru
comprendre
comment elle était toujours là mais
c'est ce qui m'a été confirmé après il
ya quelque chose qui m'a frappé quand je
me suis documenté sur le sur cet univers
c'est que on met souvent en lumière ceux
qui réussissent mais l'histoire de la
montagne de l'alpinisme est jalonnée de
mort et il ya toujours je viens d dès
qu'il ya déjà un peu fou pour faire des
choses folles mais bien souvent
finissent par mourir c'est dramatique
mais c'est comme ça et j'ai aussi voulu
traiter ce cet aspect là en parlant de
mètres de ce qui reste avec le deuil de
des aventuriers le personnage dabou
qu'est donc
rien dévoilé mais qui est donc un
personnage central et qui va donc sûr
c'est sur cette montagne exceptionnelle
ne cherche pas la gloire en réalité lui
il fait ça pour semer brest personnel
sas aspirants partie de la vie d'un
alpiniste japonais qui a existé qui
s'appelait masaru morita qui est décédée
pour le coup dans les grandes jorasses
dans les alpes ici en france grandes
jorasses gravi et pour la première fois
par sa face nord en solo il ya quelques
semaines par un français qui salue même
charles dubouloz
dans l' île expérience assez
exceptionnel qu'est la sienne notamment
parce qu'il est monté en partie en solo
intégral c'est-à-dire sans corde ce qui
était assez dingue après son exploit
dans les grandes jorasses et qu'il était
presque étonné du retentissement de son
exploit oui parce que c'est un truc en
fait ça fait partie de ces défis ce
super
importante dans le milieu en fait dans
le milieu de la montagne en fait il ya
quelques trucs comme ça évidemment
gravir l'everest ça c'est très connu
mais il ya ces phase particulière c'est
face nord souvent les plus dures de
certaines certaines montagnes et ça ça
fait partie des 15 jours assène donc oui
évidemment c'est s'est
entendu pour revenir au film je voudrais
qu'on parle un peu de la technique que
vous avez utilisé pour le faire on est
en 2d
c'est le dessin est à ce point bien fait
si je peux me permettre qu'on a vertige
en le regardant alors passer de la 2d
faut expliquer la donnée par rapport à
la 3d parce qu'avant on disait pas de
déon nous s'était dessiné à la main
aujourd'hui il y à il ya des techniques
de l'image de synthèse
c'est un peu ce qu'on voit dans les
consulats américains comme la reine des
neiges ou carte pour ça c'est de la 3d
on a fait aussi en france évidemment
mais ce film là et est en 2d c'est à
dire c'est la méthode traditionnelle
comme dans les vieux disney ou comme
avant en fait comme il ya un siècle où
en fait on dessine à la main alors
aujourd'hui on le fait via les
ordinateurs mais c'est quand même fait à
la main et donc j'ai une méthode
complète d'un traditionnel qui nous
demande de dessiner chaque dessin les
uns après les autres et pour une seconde
de film ya 12 ou 24 en fonction des
moments des simples pour faire pour
donner vie aux personnages est ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'en france on est très
bon là dessus on est pas mal ouais on
est pas mal on est pas mal
il ya environ l'animation elle se
partage en deux grands mondes d'un grand
univers dans le monde il ya les
américains qui font beaucoup de 3d
aujourd'hui il ya les japonais qui font
énormément de 2d traditionnelle au
milieu il ya nous on n'est pas très
grand mais on est assez débrouillard et
en tire assez bien notre épingle du jeu
et on met on est débrouillard aussi bien
en 3d qu'en 2d mais il se trouve que la
2d est un peu moins cher et dans plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre un peu plus
fluide et elle se prête à des projets
comme ça et puis soit vous avez aussi
beaucoup travaillé sur le sont parce que
c'est bien sûr un film qui se passe pour
la plupart du temps en extérieur et
qu'elle extérieur comment on fait en
studio pour reproduire voilà une
avalanche une ascension un crampon qui
qui se met dans une dans une bande la
glace et ben voila vous parlez
d'immersion tout à l'heure l'immersion
el wiam à elle tient aux images puisque
c'est ce qu'on voit sur grand écran mais
il ya aussi le son c'est la combinaison
des deux qui qui qui jouent et le son
c'est c'était un gros gros travailleur
c'est pas moi qui les fais parce que moi
je m'occupe de la partie image donc
c'est une équipe de designers sonores si
on peut dire qui a mais qui a travaillé
pendant longtemps là dessus il travaille
sur la base d' images qui sont pas
définitives mais oui voix le mouvement
il voit un petit peu les couleurs quand
elles sont prêtes et puis là ils vont
aller chercher soi d'un des banques
dimanche déjà prête soit ils vont
fabriquer des sens quand on voit des
fois des reportages à la télé avec les
porteurs qui fabrique un petit peu tout
et ce qui est génial en fait c'est que
le son qu'on aime qu'on ressent être
celui de la neige par exemple dans le
film et pas forcément fait avec de la
neige il peut être fait avec autre chose
et c'est un peu le c'est ça qui est
magique avec avec le sont qu'en donne
l'illusion d'une réalité alors que bien
souvent tout est faux et le et si on
combine c'est avec une bonne image une
bonne musique normalement on y est c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'on a voulu faire dans
la toute la partie montagne ouais
d'ailleurs ce qui est super dans la dans
la création du film est-ce que c'est lié
au fait que que qu'on parle un univers
particulier c'est que dans les studios
sont venus pour le coup des vrais
alpinistes des pros qui vous ont pour
que les mouvements notamment des
ascensions soit parfaitement réel et je
crois que d'ailleurs le milieu a
confirmé que c'était bien fait il vous
en montrer parfait malade comment
comment on fait avec un crampon est ce
que cette pente et réaliste il parce
qu'en fait il ya une dimension le
technique qui est très forte cd des
mouvements techniques l'alpinisme en
fait pas n'importe quoi et puis on vous
respectez ça évidemment vous voulez pas
maltraités notre sujet donc oui on a eu
on a eu les consultants et certains qui
sont venus au studio et qui nous en
disant qu'ils ont ils ont mimé ils ont
fait les geler tout ce qu'on avait prévu
au story-board et on appris un tas de
photos pour pour bien voir comment on
faisait un peu comme en pointe et une
broche à glace parce qu'il ya une
méthode très particulière pour la
plainte et ça ne fait pas n'importe
comment et d'ailleurs c'était c'était
très très technique un peu on le fera
plus c'est trop dur avec un regret
peut-être celui que tu en ingouchie donc
l'auteur du manga qui lui-même
d'ailleurs s'inspirer d'un premier récit
fait par un romancier japonais n'a pas
vu le film il est décédé en 2010 est
décédé pendant le on va dire la pré
production de films et bien évidemment
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il le voie
j'aurais aimé qu'il voit qu'ils aiment
surtout et j'en avais compris les
prémices quoi l'esprit vihear est il
avait vu du matériel de pré-production
et puis l'avait pas dit grand chose dans
la mesure où comme il savait que quand
on fait une adaptation qui était
adaptateur lui-même il faut être libre
donc il nous laissait libre et mais moi
j'ai toujours eu à coeur de faire
quelque chose qui ressemble un peu à ce
qu'il fait puisque je me suis nourri du
sommet des dieux de cette bd bien sûr
mais aussi de d'autres mais dès qu'il a
fait et donc je suis lecteur et j'ai
essayé de chercher ce qui était un peu
ça sa patte son point de vue son univers
et donc je je me dis alors peut-être
pour me rassurer mais qu'il aurait bien
aimé mais le sommet des dieux on le
rappelle ses cinq tomes sept grand prix
d'angoulême festival de bd bien connu à
en 2100 400000 exemplaires vendus énorme
succès et on leur dit même si on n'est
pas forcément familier de la montagne
c'est une aventure exceptionnelle et
donc le sommet des dieux le film pour le
coq est sorti en dvd aux césars dont
catégorie et meilleur film d'animation
bonne chance à vous on vous le souhaite
merci encore dit ce matin sur le plateau
de paray direct